>>> WELCOME BACK TO "CBS THIS
MORNING."
WE'RE ABOUT TO HEAR FROM ONE OF
THE 12 JURORS WHO CONVICTED
FIRED MINNEAPOLIS POLICE OFFICER
DEREK CHAUVIN OF MURDERING
GEORGE FLOYD.
CHAUVIN AS YOU KNOW NOW FACES UP
TO 40 YEARS IN PRISON AT HIS
SENTENCING WHICH HAS BEEN
SCHEDULED FOR JUNE 25th.
A DIVERSE JURY DELIBERATED FOR
ABOUT TEN HOURS AFTER THREE
WEEKS OF OFTEN EMOTIONAL
TESTIMONY.
THE JURORS' NAMES WERE WITHHELD
DURING THE PROCESS.
31-YEAR-OLD BRANDON MITCHELL WAS
KNOWN ONLY AS JUROR NUMBER 52,
AND HE JOINS US NOW.
BRANDON, WE'RE REALLY GLAD TO
SEE YOU BECAUSE ALL OF US WANTED
TO KNOW WHAT HAPPENED.
SO I'D LIKE YOU IF YOU COULD,
PLEASE TAKE US INSIDE THE ROOM.
I THINK WE WERE SURPRISED THAT
YOU'RE 12 STRANGERS, DIDN'T KNOW
EACH OTHER, YOU GO IN THE ROOM.
WHAT'S THE PROCESS, AND HOW WERE
YOU ABLE TO REACH A VERDICT SO
QUICKLY?
AND GOOD MORNING.
>> YEAH.
ABSOLUTELY.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
FIRST, I WANT TO SEND MY
CONDOLENCES TO THE FLOYD FAMILY.
>> YES.
>> BUT WHEN WE WALKED INTO THE
DELIBERATION ROOM, THE FIRST
THREATENING WE DID IS WE VOTED
ON WHETHER OR NOT WE WANTED TO
HAVE OUR MASK ON.
WE MADE THAT KIND OF AN ICE
BREAKER TO GET GOING.
WE VOTED TO NOT HAVE OUR MASKS
ON.
WE TOOK OUR MASKS OFF.
WE VOTED FOR A FOREPERSON, AND
FROM THERE WE WENT STRAIGHT INTO
THE MANSLAUGHTER CHARGES AND
TOOK A PRELIMINARY VOTE BEFORE
DOING A FINAL VOTE ON THOSE
CHARGES.
WENT FORWARD FROM THERE.
>> WHAT WAS THE PRELIMINARY
VOTE?
>> THE PRELIMINARY VOTE WAS 11
OF US WERE ALREADY -- WE WERE
ALREADY ON BOARD FOR GUILTY FOR
THE MANSLAUGHTER.
ONE PERSON WAS UNSURE.
AND WE JUST WENT OVER IT AS A
TEAM, AS A GROUP.
EACH PERSON KIND OF WENT DOWN
THE LINE ON WHY THEY THOUGHT IT
WAS GUILTY.
WE DID ANOTHER VOTE MAYBE 40
MINUTES LATER AFTER WE WENT
THROUGH EVERYBODY, AND EVERYBODY
WAS ON THE SAME PAGE FOR THE
MANSLAUGHTER.
I HAPPENED REALLY QUICKLY.
>> DID YOU DO THAT WITH EACH OF
THE CHARGES?
IS THAT WHAT YOU DID, TOOK A
VOTE ON EACH OF THE CHARGES?
>> YEAH, ABSOLUTELY.
EACH CHARGE WE DID THE
PRELIMINARY VOTE TO SEE WHERE WE
WERE AT, IF THERE WAS ANYBODY
THAT WAS NOT ON BOARD YET OR WAS
UNSURE.
THEN WE WOULD GO AROUND THE
ROOM, EVERYBODY KIND OF SPEAK ON
WHAT THEY -- WHAT THEY THINK IS
NECESSARY TO SPEAK ON.
WE WENT OVER MAYBE A LITTLE BIT
OF THE EVIDENCE.
AND THEN WE WOULD COME BACK WITH
A FINAL VOTE WHENEVER WE THOUGHT
IT WAS A SUITABLE TIME.
>> WHAT WAS THE ONE PERSON
UNSURE ABOUT, BRANDON?
>> I THINK IT WAS LIKE -- JUST
THE TERMINOLOGY.
SO WITHIN THE INSTRUCTIONS, SOME
OF THE TERMINOLOGY CAN BE A
LITTLE TRICKY.
BECAUSE IT'S LEGAL JARGON.
AND SO SOMETIMES SOME OF THE
WORDS CAN BE INTERPRETED
DIFFERENTLY AMONGST PEOPLE.
IT WAS JUST THEY WANTED TO DO
THEIR DUE DILIGENCE AND MAKE
SURE THAT THEY WERE COMING OUT
WITH THE RIGHT VERDICT THAT THEY
BELIEVED IN.
SO THEY WAS HUNG UP ON A FEW
WORDS.
WE WENT THROUGH THE DEFINITIONS
THAT WERE GIVEN TO US AND KIND
OF BROKE IT DOWN FROM DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVES TO GET EVERYBODY ON
THE SAME PAGE.
>> WAS THERE ANY PARTICULAR
WITNESS THAT MOVED YOU AND MOVED
THE JURY THAT YOU SAID, OKAY,
WE'RE DEEPLY AFFECTED BY FILL IN
THE BLANK?
>> YEAH.
SO I THINK AS A WHOLE JURY, I
THINK DR. TOBIN WAS THE BIGGEST,
THE MOST INFLUENTIAL WITNESS OUT
OF EVERYBODY.
FOR ME PERSONALLY, DONNA
WILLIAMS WAS ANOTHER PERSON.
SO DONNA WILLIAMS AND DR. TOBIN
--
>> THE FIGHTER -- THE MIXED
MARTIAL FIGHTER.
>> I FELT HE SET THE TONE FOR
THE TRIAL.
WHEN DR. TOBIN CAME, WITH HIM
SPEAKING SO SCIENTIFICALLY BUT
ALSO MAKING IT UNDERSTANDABLE
FOR EVERYONE ALONG WITH THE
EXHIBITS THAT HE CAME WITH, I
THOUGHT HE JUST BROKE IT DOWN IN
A MANNER THAT WAS EASY FOR ALL
THE JURORS TO UNDERSTAND.
AND I DIDN'T THINK THERE WAS ANY
WAY TO -- FOR THE DEFENSE TO
COME BACK AFTER THAT.
I WAS LIKE -- TO ME, THE CASE
WAS -- IT WAS DONE AT THAT POINT
ALMOST.
>> DID YOU FEEL PRESSURE BECAUSE
YOU KNEW THE WORLD WAS WATCHING?
THAT, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE TO REACH
A GUILTY VERDICT HERE?
>> NOT AT ALL.
AND I DON'T THINK -- I DON'T
THINK ANY OF US FELT LIKE THAT.
I FOR SURE DID NOT.
I FOR SURE DID NOT FEEL LIKE
THAT.
THE PRESSURE MORE SO CAME FROM
JUST BEING IN THE ROOM AND BEING
UNDER STRESS.
BUT IT WASN'T PRESSURE TO COME
TO A GUILTY VERDICT.
>> WHAT WERE YOU STRESSED ABOUT?
WHAT WERE YOU ALL STRESSED
ABOUT?
>> WE WERE JUST STRESSED ABOUT
JUST THE SIMPLE FACT THAT
EVERYDAY WE HAD TO COME IN AND
WATCH A BLACK MAN DIE.
THAT IS STRESSFUL.
COMING IN EACH AND EVERY DAY AND
HAVING TO WATCH SOMEBODY DIE IS
-- IS STRESSFUL ENOUGH BY
ITSELF.
SECONDARY JUST BECAUSE AS A
HUMAN, IT'S NATURAL TO FEEL SOME
KIND OF WAY AS YOU'RE WATCHING
SOMEBODY IN AGONY.
>> YEAH.
I CAN'T IMAGINE, BRANDON, WHAT
IT WAS LIKE TO BE ABLE TO WATCH
THAT TAPE DAY AFTER DAY AFTER
DAY THE WAY YOU ALL DID.
>> YEAH.
IT DEFINITELY HAD ITS -- IT HAS
ITS IMPACT ON ME.
THERE WAS A FEW DAYS WHERE I WAS
LIKE, I DON'T KNOW -- I DON'T
KNOW HOW I'M GOING TO MAKE IT IN
THIS NEXT DAY, ESPECIALLY ME AS
A BLACK MAN.
AND A LARGER BLACK MAN, I'M
6'4", 250 POUNDS.
SOME OF THE TESTIMONY IS LIKE
SAYING HOW SIZE CAN BE
CONSIDERED LIKE, YOU KNOW, IS IT
A RISK OR THREAT.
WHEREAS ME, I'M A GENTLE GIANT,
STUFF LIKE THAT, THAT AFFECTS ME
IN A WAY THAT -- IT'S WEIRD.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT AFFECTS
ANYBODY THE SAME WAY.
>> I UNDERSTAND.
I UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
HOW DID YOU ALL FEEL ABOUT DEREK
CHAUVIN, THE FACT THAT HE DID
NOT TAKE THE STAND?
WOULD THAT HAVE MADE A
DIFFERENCE DO YOU THINK -- WE'LL
NEVER KNOW IT, BUT DO YOU THINK
IT WOULD HAVE MADE A DIFFERENCE?
>> IT POSSIBLY -- IT POSSIBLY
COULD HAVE.
WE DID TALK ABOUT, YOU KNOW, THE
FACT THAT HE DIDN'T.
SOMEBODY WELL BROUGHT IT UP LIKE
THEY WISHED HE WOULD HAVE.
THEY WOULD HAVE LIKED TO HAVE
HEARD FROM HIM.
SINCE IT WASN'T PART OF THE
CASE, IT IS WHAT IT IS.
BUT YEAH, I MEAN, ANYTHING
BROUGHT IN OR NOT BROUGHT IN, IT
COULD HAVE POSSIBLY AFFECTED IT
EITHER WAY.
I CAN'T SAY IT WOULD HAVE
CHANGED THE OUTCOME, BUT IT'S A
POSSIBILITY FOR SURE.
>> DO YOU WORRY ABOUT YOUR
SAFETY NOW?
THIS WAS SUCH A CONTROVERSIAL
CASE.
WE NOW KNOW YOUR NAME, WHAT YOU
LOOK LIKE, WE KNOW THAT YOU SAID
YOU'RE A LARGE MAN.
DO YOU WORRY ABOUT YOUR SAFETY?
>> NO, NOT AT ALL.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> NOT AT ALL.
I'M -- I'M A PERSON THAT KIND OF
THRIVES IN THE POSITIVES.
SO I'M NOT TOO MUCH CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT.
NOR DO I DWELL ON --
>> WHAT THE IFs --
>> ON NEGATIVITY LIKE THAT.
YEAH, THE WHAT IFs.
>> HE'S GOING TO BE SENTENCED
JUNE 25th.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS THE PROPER
SENTENCE FOR HIM, FOR DEREK
CHAUVIN?
HE'S FACING UP TO 40 YEARS.
>> YEAH.
I COULDN'T SAY WHAT THE PROPER
SENTENCING WOULD BE.
YOU KNOW, I THINK WE CAME UP
WITH THE RIGHT VERDICT.
YOU KNOW -- GUILTY ON ALL
CHARGES.
AND YOU KNOW, I'LL LET THE JUDGE
DO WHAT HE DOES.
>> ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
WE REALLY WANTED TO HEAR FROM
YOU TODAY.
IT'S BEEN A FASCINATING CASE
THAT W